are you getting into the you seem like
someone who would get into the holiday
spirit I've known you for a while you
seem like someone who would really get
into the preparations for us yes I'm
very excited about the holidays I I mean
I'm doing this Christmas story live for
Fox yes the Christmas story which
they're doing on they're doing it on
this lot I was taking a walk the other
day around the lot just to hope that
someone recognized me yeah yeah I'm the
only guy but I saw that you guys are
going to do this live yes watch the
movie A Christmas Story which they run
on TBS you know the marathon but there's
a musical done by the loblolly on guys
Pasic and paul they get a musical
version of it and it's all these fun
people Maya Rudolph's playing the mom
and Matthew Broderick's the narrator and
I'm playing the fun neighbor match
that's what I do fun neighbor that's my
stock in trade yeah so anyways I am
working on that I'm in the holiday
spirit and I was trying to kind of it's
getting me all jazzed up so I've been
making cookies and things like that who
you are you may come cookies that's nice
yes I made cookies actually with my son
I wish I did things like that more often
but I don't and I but I did have a nice
moment he's 9 and we busted out the
KitchenAid mixer you know that's about
the weight of a man those those mixers
are those giant industrial kind of
mixers I didn't blow my lumbars yeah
just lifting it but so I got that out
and we were making the cookies and you
know it's like a commercial right we had
like the music going in the background
you know like little you know James
Brown or whatever guy we're having fun
and we're cooking and my son in the
middle of it stops and he's nine he's
nine it was on his little stool you know
mixing and laughing and he says you know
mom this is um this is really cool this
is like one of those moments in a
commercial but we would be in the
background and they would be saying this
to this drug might cause suicidal
thoughts
[Laughter]
yes it is a funny kid it also means that
basically we only have old people
television on yeah all he's watching his
pharmacy is he and he likes to does he
like to mess with you
a little bit yes he is a funny yes
that's I guess yes he does my children
he doesn't have his own phone my 15 year
old does have her own phone right so she
doesn't torture me quite as often as the
young one does but he does he does he
recently I actually put on Instagram but
he he he does things like change what
Siri calls me you know stuff like that
he changes what sir he goes in and tells
Siri to call me you know tits or
whatever you you actually posted why I
did yeah this is a screen grab your
penis joke why penis joke yeah I think
the insight there is that you know he's
not gonna tell Siri which penis joke
because she's gonna have a penis joke
that she could just maybe change it up
right or whatever so right so I
discovered it because I was you know I
was trying to do Google Maps and I and I
said you know direct me towards whatever
at the airport and she said penis joke
which Airport that's this guy's right
this guy that drove you is absolutely
right yeah that's why he wants nothing
to do with it yeah so we think they do
razz me and they you know they take
pictures of my butt when I'm not looking
and just you know that wait a minute
what like in line like we were in line
at the passport office and they were
playing with my phone and like months
later I just found a really amazing Lowe
perspective picture of my ass because
they were sure I loved it was kind of
like you know just I love that and I
love that you're gonna find it later on
it's all about discovering Italy but
what happens is sometimes you're
flipping through and you're showing
somebody let me find that picture of my
head and you know that's when there's
kind of a dumpy picture of my ass in the
middle of it it's not even like I was
sexting someone it's just like check
this out
it's a it's a it's a fifty year old
woman and dungaree to ask that's my
fantasy
you